it's outrageous enough that hundreds of
illegal immigrants are preparing to
cross the border from Tijuana into
California this weekend and ask for
political asylum but perhaps even more
outrageous that this this caravan of
Central Americans has been organized
aided and abetted and coached by
us-based activists from this group
called Pueblo sinfronteras
now why I have the media turned a blind
eye to the role played by the group's
project coordinator Alex men Singh who
is also a program assistant at the
University of San Francisco's
immigration clinic let's get into that
with a pair of immigration attorneys Dan
Stein is in Tampa and Francisco
Hernandez is in Fort Worth Texas dan
let's start with you here this is this
is quite something
we have American NGOs and other NGOs
working to get the the publicity going
for this group they they come every year
around Easter time and they make their
way into Mexico Mexico usually disbands
them quite effectively and they actually
started to disband them before I think
the president started tweeting about it
a couple weeks ago but you have these
lawyers who basically embed with the
groups who are American lawyers and
they're going over okay this is what you
say for credible fear of persecution and
then they show up on buses and then they
all start reciting the same lines I mean
it seems like it's encouraging people to
to game the system
maybe laurits it's aiding and abetting
it's it's organized smuggling I mean
they made the media make it sound like
they think it's like a street fair
they're coming in for a festival then
they're going back to Honduras that's
not what's happening this is actually
organized smuggling look as long as the
United States remains a free capitalist
and open society there will be millions
of people around the world who would
like to come here but not everybody can
come and a sovereign nation like the US
has the right to control who comes into
the country and who doesn't
groups like people Without Borders do
not subscribe to that idea so this
effort is part of an overriding
organized effort we see across the world
we see it in Europe we now see it in the
Gaza with Israel we see
all around the world to try to challenge
Western societies to prevent them from
using their immigration laws to stop the
systemic organized smuggling under the
banner of asylum all the people coming
in have been coached and you know what I
feel sorry for the folks coming here a
lot of look like really nice good people
but the point is if only refugees can
get in then everybody wants to be called
you know called a refugee and so they
get coached in they know that if they
make a credible fear claim if there's no
detention space they're going to be
released for years before they get the
asylum hearing and luckily the Trump
administration is taking steps to stop
this by using a rocket doctrine and
deploying immigration judges to expedite
the removal right let's get Francisco in
here Francisco Mexico sure has tried to
help out here and at various points
including by you know telling telling
the folks look you have 30 days to leave
Mexico like you have 30 days we'll give
you a transit visa and then you have to
leave Mexico so what their point is is
Mexican officials have said if you want
Asylum will give you asylum I mean and
but the but they have made it clear in
various sources have told me that the
Hondurans overwhelmingly are hardened
doin's don't want to be in mexico so
they're not interested in leave going to
any country except our country now why
is that except except the promised land
but look listen to what you guys are
saying are we now against legal
immigration asylum law is a legal
process by which these folks can apply
to come in they either have proof or
they don't you can't coach proof but
what they're trying to come in under a
legal process that is or law they're not
coming across there's no smuggling
there's no illegal entry into the United
States they're applying to come into the
United States legally isn't that what we
wanted and you know what if there's 400
of them right there at the border maybe
President Trump can bring him some
bricks and we can start building the
wall well I think was in so we spent
about a hundred and sixteen billion
dollars all told on illegal immigration
when you add that up that would be how
many walls like five walls four hundred
sixteen but we're talking about illegal
immigration yeah no we're talking about
people who come here illegal in the
illegally in the United States and many
of the people who've been interviewed
said no and the people who hold on hold
on who have disbanded from the group say
we're going to get
like we're gonna get there if we don't
get in as asylees we're gonna get in I
mean they're looking they're very
illegal immigration no no sorry legal
immigration system that are invoking the
asylum laws that is the law of the land
is code are you saying that you don't
believe there is fraud in the asylum
application of the asylum laws in the
United States you're saying tonight sure
there isn't it's in and immigration is
very good at ferrying it out that you
can't coach proof they the problem here
is you're not witnesses well we'll hold
on you're not putting on we know this
you're not you're an immigration
attorney do you think these 24 year old
mother of three is putting on who's
going to determine and okay here's my
documents oh they don't have any
document grim miss Ingram who's gone for
years but the US agents it's the Trump
administration sages they're going to
determine whether these people can prove
immediate fear it's not like there's all
these social programs going out it is a
hard threshold to prove and it is a way
I think it's 75 to 93% of people who
apply for asylum in this process they
ultimately get it or they ultimately get
released anyway during the process it's
less than 10% now they get released into
this dan do they not get released after
they've applied the first the first
standard is what's called credible fear
it's a very low threshold all you have
to say is I'm afraid to go home they can
request they can request the hearing
before an immigration judge the problem
is the cases get backlog they get
released into the society they're here
for years they never I wish I had a
dollar for every alien who after doing a
credible fear claim doesn't show up for
the immigration hearing I wish I had a
dollar for every time an alien who's
ordered deported doesn't show up for
their deportation or $1 for me I mean it
goes on and on and all this is this is a
massive mess I mean we have a mess
change the law in France trouble
administration is trying to change the
law check this out Francisco I'm saying
you're absolutely right
these laws do need to be changed because
the way the asylum laws are written now
are easy it's easily GameA below
okay so that's even a word it's easily
it's easily good and it has it is it
does have to change well hold on hell it
does have to be changed because it's
actually putting the migrants lives at
risk you have these kids rotting that
are being they're being manipulated and
being and they're being hurt by these
gangs and recruited by gangs this is
this is a humanitarian a nightmare agree
that we've helped create so we've got if
we've got a glacial thank you for saying
that that was absolutely one by the way
by the way just a fact for our audience
we're running over do it this this just
came out today by the federal government
the federal government loses track of
20% of the unaccompanied children within
three months of their arriving here this
was HHS testimony today they've lost
track of seven hundred seven hundred
sixty-seven thousand six hundred
thirty-five unaccompanied children that
they had to check in with over the last
three months three months of the last
three months of last year they lost
track of 1500 of those after 30 to Laura
we don't know the media people who's
still sitting there doing many of the
people who say that they're fleeing or
actually they say they're fleeing gang
violence but in fact a lot of these
unaccompanied minors are recruited by
gang ms-13 in this country so we have a
direct relationship between gang
violence at the border next week
Francisco let's go to and the tequila
shots are on me okay it's all about
drink you're on I'll buy drinks for
everybody